but you better get one body and one mind
and that's all you're gonna get you make
stupid short-term decisions and we don't
have perspective to think about the long
term because if you're not healthy will
not be happy
rise and shine
it's an espresso time what's up believe
nation it's Evan I believe in you and
this channel is designed to be a part of
your daily success routine so let's
start your day off right together grab
your coffee and sip on today's message
take care of your body and mind over to
you Warren Buffett also if you want to
know what Warren Buffett and other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about the unstoppable confidence Tecton
my24 series where every day for the next
254 days I will send you in a morning
video for free to help you build your
confidence to link to join with in the
description below it's important to
associate with people who are better
than yourself seventy years ago I was in
high school almost a third as long as
the country has been around and when I
was in high school I really only had two
things on my mind
girls and cars and and I wasn't doing
very well with girls so we'll talk about
cars but let's just imagine that when we
finish I'm gonna let each one of you
pick out the car of your choice sounds
good doesn't it pick it out any color
you name it it'll be tied up with a bowl
and I'll be at your house tomorrow
and you say well what's the catch and
the catch is that it's the only car
you're going to get in your lifetime now
what are you going to do knowing that
that's the only car you're ever going to
have and you love that car you're going
to take care of it but you cannot
believe now what I'd like to suggest
you're not going to get only one car in
your lifetime but you're going to get
one body and one mind and that's all
you're gonna get and that body of mine
feels terrific now but it has to last
you a lifetime
people lock perspective and so they make
stupid short-term decisions you see it
in health we'd rather eat the Doritos or
those Junior Mints because it gives us
that short-term verse meanwhile it's
sacrificing our long-term health you see
it in entrepreneurship all the time
where people are constantly jumping from
one opportunity to the next just trying
to make money just trying to pay off
some bills and having 18 different side
hustles meanwhile never actually
building anything of substance we make
stupid short-term decisions and we don't
have perspective to think about the
long-term I had a woman come out on my
tour who she's trying to build this
charity and she's trying to build this
amazing business for herself but
meanwhile she's got eight different side
hustles from ice cream trucks to a whole
bunch of different side and none of them
are working like they're working just
enough to pay a little bit of money and
so you stick with it because it gives
you that little tiny taste meanwhile
you're not building anything towards the
long-term it's why people can't get out
of their cell phones and can't get off
of their emails I used to pride myself
as being the guy who would answer an
email within a minute and a half right
like quick boom you send me an email
you're getting response ASAP right away
that's good customer service right and
then people would respond back and say
wow you're so fast on Iman that fed the
dopamine right like I'm getting these
little quick hits but what happened
nothing got done on my big projects
nothing got done on my big projects
because I constantly was being
distracted and handling these little
tiny balls instead of working towards
the big ones you can't be a master of
both at the same time you have to decide
I'm either gonna go for the big things
in life my big goals my big mission my
big vision or I'm gonna go for the
little small ones constantly and if you
go for the big ones it means you got
to give up some of the small ones some
small things are gonna get through the
cracks that's okay
but if you're only focused on the small
things you will never hit your big goals
curate so I think it's an issue of
perspective we forget about the long
term we forget about the long run
because it's so far away because you
don't want to think about the rest of
your life you think about what's
happening right now you're tired now
you're hungry now you need money right
now you think about the now and you lose
perspective over where you're going and
so you make stupid short-term decisions
so I'm gonna give you a three-step
process that I think will help you shift
you realign you they have to do in a
regular basis so that you don't make
those stupid decisions number one is
regularly shift your perspective remind
yourself of what you trying to
accomplish remind yourself of your goals
remind yourself of your mission if it's
a health one remind yourself that you
want to live to be however many years
old you want to live to see your great
great grandkids grow up you want to live
to enjoy the beautiful amazing world
that we have here you want to live a
long life for your business you want to
create something amazing you want to
change the way something's done in the
world and yes the very real thing that
you have coming up with up bill you have
to pay that's real but don't be stupid
remember where you have to go right
remind yourself of the mission that
you're on so you have to regularly shift
your perspective regularly to remind
yourself because it's so great and easy
to sit down and watch a Netflix series
and just binge all day and take that
Saturday off or that Friday off or that
Thursday night off or whatever it is but
you're sacrificing your long-term goals
and you can shift your perspective and
say am i proud of myself and sometimes
it's yes and sometimes that means you
should binge and you should relax and
you should wind down you need that time
for yourself because you're proud of the
reason why but too often you're not
proud of yourself the version of you and
20 years looking back was not proud of
you right now and so make that person
proud shift your perspective remind
yourself of it every single day step
number two is scheduled for success
create a schedule create a schedule that
maps to your ambitions your actions have
the map to your ambitions and so success
is habits success is not about hitting a
certain goal hitting a certain number of
dollars in your bank account or a number
of subscribers on YouTube it's about
your habits and so look at your week
look at the week that's coming up ahead
in your calendar look at the week and
put in everything your business as well
as your personal if you just scheduling
your business goals
they're gonna bleed into your entire
life and you won't have any personal
ones left isn't there's no time if your
personal life anymore there's no time
for your relationships and we have
different balances you need to have some
of that in your life
so schedule your entire ideal life
schedule your life the entire day the
entire evening weekends how are you
spending your time chunks of time I
didn't ask yourself to step above it and
look at your calendar and say if I did
these things these habits these specific
habits every week if I did those things
what I've been moving closer to my goals
would it be happy and if yest and great
go do it and if no then adjust it
because if you have these long-term
goals to yourself whether it's the
mindset whether it's your body whether
it's your business growth relationship
goals whatever they are you have
long-term goals to yourself you want to
be somewhere amazing show me in your
calendar when you're spending time on
those things if they're not in your
calendar you will never get there if you
want to be healthy but you have no
working out time when your calendar
you'll never get there if you want to be
a CEO of a big business but you have no
CEO time in your calendar you'll never
get there if you want to have a great
relationship with your husband white but
you don't have any time when your
calendar blocked off blocked up put
fences around it defenses right like
nobody touches this time for Nina Knight
Saturday every Saturday I'll take her
out to a new food place because she
loves food we'll go explore or hiking a
street festival shopping something that
she likes doing and I plan the surprise
for the whole day and we don't let other
tasks it in the way we don't let
business get in the way we don't let
cleaning up the apartment or taking out
the trash or borne a Costco get in the
way you have to put barriers and
boundaries around the time because
otherwise all these little tasks will
seep in and if you're the kind of person
at the end of a week you look back on
your calendar and say man I'm really
busy this week but I feel like I got
nothing done you're not scheduled for
success you're allowing all the little
things in life that will pop up to
destroy your entire calendar and you're
not giving any of your big long-term
stuff done so schedule for success plot
it every day plot it from Sunday to
Sunday what are you doing and then step
above a luck if I did these things would
I be successful in step number three is
how people hold you accountable have
people in your life friends family
coworkers people around you who hold you
accountable who catch you when you're
playing small who catch you when you're
cheating yourself who catch you who help
keep you in that mode of perspective I
think people play small by default I
think we do I think humans we play small
by default we're wired to play small and
we're conditioned to play small and so
if you have something that you really
want to go off and do you have a
long-term ambition a goal you want to
take care of yourself you want to invest
in yourself have somebody hold you
accountable who catches you when you say
I want to be spending three nights a
week working on my business working on
my side hustle because I have a
full-time job then is your spouse your
partner your friend holding you
accountable
did you work those three nights a week
have somebody to hold you accountable
because you will let yourself down all
day long but you won't want to let
others down and so create an
accountability system with somebody
close to you who will keep you on track
who'll keep you focused who will help
you keep that perspective in mind so you
can go off and achieve your long-term
goals instead of letting yourself down
now I've got a really special bonus clip
that I think you're going to enjoy but
before that question today I want to
know what's the most important thing
that you do to take care of your mind
and body let me know put in the comments
below I think life is a journey you come
to this world is to enjoy the life to be
happy and healthy
so the day when you leave the world you
say I'm happy in my life my health in
this life because if you're not healthy
you will not be happy so I believe happy
and healthy are the things that human
being always looking for and I think
next to 30 years because of the
technology people the life science is
gonna change a lot and people is gonna
live longer
but we can live longer that's not
necessarily live healthier so if you're
not healthy how can you be happy if you
live longer if you're not happy why you
live there
I don't drink and it's very easy for me
not to drink I tell people what are you
drinking for what are you drinking for
and they don't even understand what I'm
saying my house I said how did you work
that it's amazing when people see you
they can't imagine no no no alcohol oh
would I be in trouble if I was a drinker
no no no no no smoking yeah no smoking
well I had a brother ox I had a brother
Fred who was sadly an alcoholic a
serious alcoholic and he was the best
looking guy you've ever seen
he was much older than you he's much on
who's 10 years older than me 11 years
older than me and he was as good-looking
a guy as you've ever seen he were he and
everything going the best personality I
have like a bad personality compared to
Fred but he started drinking and he also
smoked a lot and but he he started
drinking and I think it started in
college frankly but it got progressively
worse and he was really unable to stop
and he'd always tell me don't you ever
drink so he's much older than me and it
really has an impact you know when you
have that kind of an age difference but
he'd point don't you ever drink and
don't you ever smoke he'd add the smoke
in it because he smoked any drank and it
hugely affected his health and hugely
affected even his look and his you know
for the whole bearing and every time
you'd see me you'd say don't you ever
drink and don't us so I never drank I
mean I really when you talk about my
father I learned a lot for my father but
I learned a lot for my brother Fred and
he set an example it wasn't maybe the
example that people would think but it
really was in its own way an example if
you want more Warren Buffett took at the
top 10 rules video I made on him the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
defining your circle of competence is
the most important aspect of investing